good morning John it is Monday your
thoughts from places video on Friday was
absolutely amazing thank you very much
for that nerdfighters if you did not
watch that video either because you were
away from your subscription buff or
because you did not want to click on the
tombstone evolve a couch here is your
opportunity to click on the tombstone of
Volvo couch and that will take you to
John Stott from places video at the end
of that video there will be a link back
to this video and you will get to
watched so John it occurred to me a
little while ago that you and I are a
little bit like the presidents of
nerdfighteria possibly the enlightened
despot then for several reasons that
analogy broke down because it's not
really a country sized place if you can
call this place that isn't a place a
place and nerdfighters already have
their own national government so it's
more like a town or a small city and so
thus we are more like Co mayors and so I
want to talk to a mayor about what being
a mayor is like and so I did this good
morning John good morning
this is Mozilla's Mayor John ingen and I
had a chance to talk to him and I feel
like if you have a chance to talk to
your mayor you should talk to your man
generally speaking everyone should have
a chance to talk to their mayor but
you've never was in a very large town I
have not local governments kind of the
front line this is your opportunity
really to interact so I have a card
getting question yes um below-the-belt
good gianni pets we have a rescued
Labradoodle named Odie we have a Humane
Society cat named moose and we just lost
our 13 year old greyhound my beloved
patches I have a grant do you yeah yeah
they're fantastic she's a sweetie she's
pathetic patches was what we call food
focus which is really unusual with our
family what did you do before you were
mayor jobs Gulf land which Gulf land and
indoor miniature and that's here that
was here it was we lost Gulf land quite
some time ago huh we just lost quibbles
- I feel like we're lacking for Family
Fun Center I didn't know that was a
that's the maze go-karts corn maze
arcade games generally I don't see all
that much
and I'm not allowed in bouncy things
there's a restraining order golf and
Hansons famous ice cream store and then
I worked for the local newspaper I work
for the Mizzou lien for a long time I
was mayor and compared with all the
other jobs best job I've ever had loved
the job very challenging yeah just a
fantastic education a real opportunity
to to get things done as a mayor what do
you actually do oh just if this is what
you did you talk to people in couches I
didn't think we'd get to that question I
am responsible for the day-to-day
operations of the city Missoula we have
about 500 full-time employees you're
basically the chief executive father 500
person corporation that runs a city
which I try not to think about too much
because it scares me I know really I get
my own firetruck oh I didn't know that a
few people do can you loan it out oh
sure
we do a lot of prom night in particular
probably your primary income sucks yeah
fire truck rentals yes it's all about
new revenue streams I mean most the time
they're just sitting there and there's
not there's nothing like a ladder truck
on an April evening Lady Gaga in the
background oh man yeah my wife would
love me forever no no she wouldn't she
hates it I didn't get the end part where
we shook hands and I said thank you
marrying it because my camera ran out of
card space I had a great time talking to
him if you live in Missoula you should
vote for him and again are you a
satellite or a Portland ER I'm going to
be in your city playing music with funny
people like mike phirman and pollen
storm at the end of March it's going to
be fun
tickets are $20 each and they're selling
out fast and finally nerdfighteria
sincere apologies for never letting you
challenge us to do something in return
for you figuring out the space pasta
mess please leave us challenges in the
comments they can be things like
interview your mayor which I wish
somebody had challenged me to do that
because I just did it gah that is all I
need to go eat Chinese food John I'll
see you on Wednesday
Oh